janet yellen is the secretary of the
treasury and historically she's been
very anti-bitcoin in cryptocurrencies
but recently there may be the tide
turning it seems like janet yellen has
now come around and is maybe becoming a
crypto proponent it's pretty wild to
watch this now as a reminder here's the
background on janet yellen in 2018 as
the chair of the federal reserve she
said she was not a fan of bitcoin janet
yellen is now the 78th secretary of the
treasury and earlier this month she
along with other government agencies
were tasked by president biden his
administration to begin the process of
creating a regulatory framework for the
crypto industry now in a recent
interview with andrew ross sorkin of
cnbc janet yellen had some very
interesting and potentially positive
things to say about bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies here's the video for
you to go ahead and listen directly for
yourself russia just said that they
would accept
bitcoin as a payment
for
their energy
resources
what does that say to you about where we
are in the crypto conversation
well crypto is obviously grown by leaps
and bounds and
um
it's now playing a significant role not
really so much in transactions right but
in investment decisions of lots of
americans and
the president just issued a couple of
weeks ago an executive order tasking us
in other agencies with thinking about
the regulation of crypto i mean you're
less skeptical about it than in previous
i mean we've been talking about it
together for a long time now and i think
you've had a skepticism about crypto
technology i have a little bit of
skepticism because i'm um
there are cons i think valid concerns
around it some have to do with financial
stability
consumer investor protection
use for illicit transactions and other
things on the other hand there are
benefits from crypto and we recognize
that innovation in the payment system
can be a healthy thing we would like to
come out eventually with recommendations
that um will create a regulatory
environment in which healthy innovation
and then finally
now to go back to somebody who has the
chair of the federal reserve back in
2018 wasn't a fan of bitcoin has been
pretty anti-crypto for a number of years
now to hear her talking positively about
it to be getting on board with the
president's agenda for the united states
to be the leader on a global stage for
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies this is
encouraging any time that we can convert
somebody like the treasury secretary to
become more pro bitcoin pro crypto
currencies that's a positive in my mind
and so kudos to janet yellen for finally
getting new information starting to
change her mind i would love to see this
continue to see or actually start to put
forward ideas to say that the united
states needs to go ahead and be a leader
in the bitcoin world maybe even can we
have the treasury secretary advocate to
actually put bitcoin on our balance
sheet these are all things that might
have been wishful thinking a couple
years ago but after listening to
treasury secretary janet yellen start
talking positively about this industry
never say never hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time